The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I'm just going
to do Venter very quickly
since we went through this so
thoroughly previously.
But just a few wonderful
snapshots, these are The Nature
and the Science covers.
So Venter did Science and
Collins and the NIH Genome
Project did Nature.
Both published on the same day.
It's kind of the truce that got
arranged between the two sides.
And there they are
competing with each other.
And then there's
Collins on his Harley
and Venter on one of
his wild racing yachts.
And Venter is only
interested in sailing if it's
dangerous is best I can figure.
So and then there's this classic
picture Venter in the business
suit and wearing the lab coat.
You know this is all
about the contradictions
in the model he's
trying to pursue,
that fundamental
Solara contradiction.
So these are just a few.
AUDIENCE: Who's the
dude on the motorcycle?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's Francis Collins
who's currently head of NIH,
who's also a blues singer too,
by the way.
So both these folks
are a little out there.
They're both terrific talents.
They're remarkable talents.
We've talked at
length about Venter.
I think that for the purposes
here, what I want to say
is that, I put Venter in here
as an example of someone who
ran into all the contradictions
in the life science innovation
model, right?
The fact that it was
very hard for NIH
to look outside of biology.
It was all biologists
all the time.
Venter of course, was
trained as a biologist
but began moving into
this computer territory,
based upon some advances that
Leroy Hood made before him
and building on Hood's work
and doing a lot of innovations
like the genome shotgun
approach that we
talked about two weeks ago.
He ran into all of
the other series
of these institutional
problems at NIH
as an innovation organization.
That it became very
hard for him to stand up
a completely different
pathway to technology advance
and science advance.
That the system was locked
into a different route,
and they were very unaccepting.
In fact, ostracized him as
he moved in a different kind
of direction.
So he ultimately leaves.
And then we run into this
change agent kind of idea.
He becomes a competitor
and forces change
in the institution
which he left as it
tries to keep pace with him
so as not to be embarrassed.
Hence the NIH Genome Initiative.
And you know it's
just an illustration
and a very personal kind of way,
which is why I put it in here,
of some of the larger
institutional challenges
that we've been
talking about before.
So let me leave the
Venter model here
and go into the chapter,
chapter seven in our textbook.
So it's not simply NIH, but
it's the health care delivery
system itself that has these
legacy sector features.
And as we talked about
earlier on in class,
the US is pretty good at
standing up new technologies
in open fields.
It runs into real trouble
trying to stand up
technologies in these kind
of established sectors.
So in the life
science territory,
we did pretty well by
creating this completely new
biotech model which was
a we were able to get
a lot of advance out of.
But when it comes back to fixing
the whole health care delivery
system, that's proven
far more problematic.
And you know that's been a
major thorny political issue
for three administrations
in a row now.
And they've each
had rocky results
trying to pursue that question
of how we're going to organize
health care delivery systems.
So there's lots of legacy sector
characteristics in health care
delivery, perverse prices
and price structures,
established infrastructure
and institutional structures
like NIH, very powerful
vested interests.
We can see some of those in NIH.
But we can certainly see them in
other parts of the health care
delivery system.
They're sustained
by public habits.
Right?
So it's very hard to
tell Medicare patients
that their full cost repayment
system with no patient stake
doesn't make a lot
of economic sense.
They're not going
to be enthusiastic
about the alternatives.
So these are structured and
sustained by public habits.
Steph?
AUDIENCE: Can you
define no patient stake?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You
know Medicare is a full cost
reimbursement system.
And it was organized
for medicine
as we knew it 30 or
40 years ago, right?
It was a professional
delivery system.
And you would pay for the
cost of the service, whatever
that was.
You would not pay for
results, because the results
in the medical system
are too uncertain.
It was very hard
to figure out how
to estimate a pay for results
kind of outcomes oriented
repayment system for
these medical systems.
So as a result, it became a
fee for service, full payment
system for the
medical profession.
And that created
a huge incentive
to run up costs for which
the federal government would
provide you full
reimbursement, regardless
of what the outcomes were.
So trying to shift
those economic signals
has proven very problematic.
You know, Obamacare attempted
to change some of those,
not without controversy within
the medical professions.
It's averse to change
and innovation.
The established
knowledge base tends
to get locked in for
the professions that
are participants here.
There's a real problem
with collective action.
In other words, it's
scattered amongst thousands
of institutions and getting
them to act collectively
in a different kind of
organizational model
is not simple.
And there are serious
governmental and institutional
problems here.
So I won't go through
the whole litany.
But you begin to get a sense
of how you can take the legacy
sector analytical
framework and apply it
to a big economic sector that
service based like health care.
It's not just technology
based like say energy,
it's service based.
But that analytical
framework will
work to a surprising extent
for both kinds of sectors.
And let me go into--
let me go out and get this
one on the table as well,
the PCAST, propelling
innovation and drug discovery.
It's a very important
critique of the system
that came out in 2012.
PCAST is the President's
Council of Advisors
on Science and Technology.
They advise the president
on science and tech policy.
We had a very strong
PCAST under Eric Lander
during the Obama
administration a lot
did a lot of
breakthrough reports.
I think frankly, this is
one of the most significant.
They really took a hard look
at the health care innovation
system and identified a lot of
trouble, a lot of which we've
been talking about today.
But this really spelled
a fair amount of it out.
So the NIH budget doubled
between '98 and 2003.
It hasn't kept up with the
inflation costs since then.
But in parallel,
we've had rising costs
of clinical trials, which
have now actually reached,
according this report
$1.8 billion per drug.
There's a new
patent cliff that's
looming for
pharmaceutical companies.
So you may have
noticed that farmers
are busy merging and
divesting themselves
of their R&D operations.
It looks like a
problematic trend.
So why is this?
It's largely because of
this upcoming patent cliff.
Drugs with annual sales
of $200 billion dollars
will go off patent between 2010
and I think it's 2015 actually.
So this has already
been happening.
And this has forced
a restructuring
and amongst the historic
pharmaceuticals.
Replacement revenues are
not readily available.
So hence this whole set
of merger activities.
And they've been,
the pharmaceuticals
have been curtailing their R&D
as a result. Venture capital
at the time this was written
was in general decline
for all sectors,
including biopharma.
Now frankly that's in
significant part recovered now.
That's now better than it was.
This tends to be a cyclical
kind of pattern for biotechs
in the health care area.
But at this particularly
time, first time these C
deals for biotechs were down
really quite significantly.
And so that's always
an issue that we're
going to have to confront.
In other words,
biotechs only work
if the venture capital system is
willing to be quite supportive.
So ups and downs in the
venture capital sector
can have a pretty strong
effect as to whether we
get drugs emerging into the
marketplace that we need.
Despite R&D growth in past
decades, drug output was flat
and productivity was declining.
And this report
invented a concept
called Eroom's law, which is
the opposite of Moore's law.
The cost of drug development
doubles every nine years.
And the results decline.
So it's the opposite
of Moore's law Martin?
AUDIENCE: I was going to ask,
so VCs function on a seven year
time cycle for an exit?
So are biotech VCs
on a 20 year cycle?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No.
No.
But what they will
do is they will
go with different
levels of funding,
you know, A round, B round,
C round, which they'll tie--
they'll benchmark often to
the clinical trial process.
So they'll be able to
manage their risk in moving
from one stage to another.
And again, no other sector
has thought of this.
They haven't figured out
an alternative model.
The failure rate for new
drugs in clinical trials
is increasing.
So as of 2003,
that was 91% fail.
Imagine trying to
construct a profit model
around a 91% failure rate.
It's not simple.
Can still be done,
because the rewards can
be so big through the
blockbuster model.
And the guarantee of
monopoly rents to the patents
that you get for it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Are things
getting more stringent or are
the diseases getting harder?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I think it's--
you know, what am I to say?
And I don't think there are
easy answers here on this, Max.
I think that we've done
the low hanging fruit.
And the problem is getting
much more complicated.
Chris, you're nodding your head.
Does that seem like
a good answer to you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
think definitely.
Because like the
next frontier seems
to be like
personalized medicine,
which is a huge kind
of new moving problem.
Because a lot of
the difficulties
of kind of commercializing that
and kind of making that viable.
Although there's a lot of hype
around it, which is great.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: Don't
get too much data.
It could be that maybe
they're not doing as many?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well maybe
now we're doing like way more.
Or like, it's very easy.
You know they say the
worst lies are statistics.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yes, that's true.
And all of these could be lies.
AUDIENCE: Well,
it's just one way
of looking at the
problem, right?
It's a way of showcasing it.
But I would want to see
the whole data to see why,
the context behind it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
I mean generally speaking,
this report was well received.
In other words, the
experts in the community
thought that this PCAST
report was on to something,
that they had identified some
pretty critical problems.
So time to market for drugs
has also been growing.
So eight years to
market was 50 years ago
is 14 years to market now.
And the longer it
takes, the more
you eat up your
monopoly rent period,
which means you've got to
make higher profits sooner,
which means the short
term charges for the drugs
get higher.
And you're driven
and more and more
towards a blockbuster
recovery model.
So this is problematic.
And you know it particularly
affects small companies
and biotechs that can't really
manage that long term risk
period.
And there's a gap between
research and product
development as well.
And the whole
advances in science
are requiring different
kind of models here.
So now there's much
more focus on-- we'll
talk about convergence
in a little bit.
But much more focus on
multidisciplinary teams
rather than solo individual
investigator ROI type results.
You tend to have to cross
over a series of fields now
to get your medical advance out
and that's more problematic.
So ideas they
propose, NCATS they
cited, the
translational medicine
entity at NIH, that
frankly has had trouble
getting enough funding
to really scale up
to do what it needs to do, a
DARPA type model, FDA exploring
something called
predictive toxicology,
and predictive toxicity with a
lab on a chip kind of approach.
In other words, there's
new technologies
that could be breakthroughs
here in trying
to solve concept problems.
So let me-- let's
get through these
I think we can just
touch very briefly
on Craig Venter and
then kind of dig
into the legacy sector
reading, into the PCAST report.
Just a quick question on Venter.
Yeah, you got him, Good.
AUDIENCE: I think
Venter's discovery
is one of the closest to
[INAUDIBLE] ethical problems.
And just now we had a
discussion about how
we want to speed up of all
the research on antibiotics.
So I want to ask, how do we
balance this raising concern,
by raising concerns
of the public
all this about related
research and the need.
There's a need for better
drugs and better discoveries,
in the sense that
there is, like there
is no mention the role of
media in his discovery.
Is that without the media
pushing his results,
pushing his discoveries,
his team and his work
wouldn't be approved by
this parent organization.
And the kind of discussion
raised in public kind of
gave him enough
support to continue
this [INAUDIBLE] process.
So I would say what are
the other ways to kind
of balance this raising concerns
and this need for better drugs?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It's a
very interesting point, Luyao.
The fact that Venter was able
to mobilize media support, get
them to understand the potential
importance of these projects,
and what the possibilities
were, in effect help drive
support for this whole
genome initiative,
whether it was Venter's
or whether it was NIH's,
it was a very powerful input.
And we saw him and Collins on
the cover of Time Magazine.
That was just one example of
the kind of media attention
on this great scientific race.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
everyone was saying,
everyone has their
genetic information,
everyone was concerned.
And how can this--
I mean, the future will
probably be more concerns.
Is there any possible way
to address this balance?
AUDIENCE: So you're saying
like change the structure so
that somebody who
has a good idea
doesn't have to like
completely go and fight
the current structure for it?
AUDIENCE: I want to
say like how do we
inform the public of this,
the potential benefits that it
brings, but also ensures
that things are under--
AUDIENCE: Are actually worth--
yes I mean, I think a lot about
like the cold fusion scandal.
Where like they said
they had it to the public
so that they would
get attention for it.
But like the science
wasn't super like sure.
And so like there
is a huge danger,
especially in the
scientific community, where
you need to make sure
something actually
works and it's been
tested by your peers
before you go public,
especially if it's
a dramatic discovery, which I
think the genomics project was.
And so that is a very
hard position to be in.
At the same time,
though, I think
he leveraged a good
amount of that.
I think it's more about
being a little more slightly
or Machiavellian in
understanding the structure
and like who can
kill you in terms
of like credibility
or other stuff.
So he did a good job
of actually making
sure the science was good, kind
of having some stakeholders
just approve his stuff.
But going to the
media and saying,
yo, this is why they're
going to mess up
and is why we're
doing pretty well.
And we're kind of a
David versus Goliath.
Check it out.
It's pretty interesting.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
We don't usually
talk about the role of media in
innovation and science policy.
But you are right to point
us in this direction.
Because this was a highly
public competition.
I mean as I say
here, it creates--
that competition could be viewed
as just duplicative, right?
Why are private and
public resources
in effect duplicating
each other in this race?
But on the other hand, it
was incredibly creative
and it spurred both sides to
greatly accelerate and focus
on the problems.
So I think the duplicative
research thesis really
doesn't work here.
But the other
dimension you add here
is, you know, how can innovators
use public attention in helping
to drive towards their goal.
And we watched in
the Boyer and Swanson
case, how Swanson was able
to mobilize media coverage
and hold major press conferences
when he had major announcements
to make, he and Boyer
had major announcements
to make on their team.
So it's a dimension that I
don't think anybody's really
spent a lot of time looking at
in an organized kind of way.
But it's a very interesting one.
How does public support
affect your ability
to drive an innovation project?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it seems to me
that oftentimes, the
general American public only
gets really interested
in the scientific topic
when something's going really,
really badly, like epidemic, is
where people are like
hm, biology and medicine
are important.
Or like you know, my favorite
example of the Apollo 13
disaster was when suddenly
everyone cared about space,
but only because people
were about to die
and it was exciting.
So maybe some sort of response
to the science communication
problem would be getting
information out there
about the value of preventing
the ratings grabbing disasters,
I guess.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
look as cool, though.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
of science fiction.
That's kind of the role
There's like a utility
principle that I--
her name is-- can't
remember her last name
I took a course on
bioethics last semester.
It was a part of
something called
the [INAUDIBLE] seminars for
public writing at Wellesley.
And this woman who was,
I guess, was coming in
to speak with us about
the role of media
in establishing bioethics,
and specifically
about genetic engineering.
And one of the points that
she made to a question
that I had asked was
precisely that science fiction
plays an enormous role in
helping the public become
comfortable with scientific
advances far before the time
that those scientific advances
are even technically feasible.
And so, maybe as the
scientific community, or rather
the scientific community
should do a better job
of involving themselves in
the narrative storytelling
process about what science
is and has the potential
to be in order to
sort of set the stage
for those scientific
advancements when time comes.
And there is I think a
huge market, thinking
about Martin's sort of business
proclivity in children's books
about science fiction,
and the ways in which we,
as maybe someday parents,
right, could be right in reading
these stories to our children
at night, having them think
about the future and
that aspect of science
communication and especially
science communication
to the younger generations
which will inherit
the kinds of innovations
that we create today,
are immensely important.
But there's not a
lot of storytellers
who are equipped with
the technical knowledge
in order to communicate
that adequately in a way
that's palatable to
children and it's also
palatable to their parents and
to the broader American market.
So I think it's really
important to think
about this sort of storytelling
dimensions of science
communication, not just in the
sense of, what's in the news,
or what's going to
be in the newspapers,
but how we are
orienting ourselves
to make this an issue
we care about socially.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I like the
idea of preparing the stage so
that people are receptive to
advancements when they happen,
and not just the scientist
makes a discovery
and then suddenly is trying to
drum up support for something
that they have to explain,
A, why it's important first
of all, and then, B, why
what they've discovered
is the relevant.
You make good points.
AUDIENCE: Do you
remember who came up
with the rockets, the
original rocket that
came from like Germany?
AUDIENCE: Von Braun.
AUDIENCE: Von Brian.
Yeah, so that's a
pretty good example.
Because von Braun
was having a lot
of difficulty getting funding
for the rockets originally.
So what he did is he
wrote a letter to Disney,
because he was a foreigner.
He was German, so like no one
wanted him to actually do it.
And they were kind
of stifling him
and they put him in
a research facility
where he wasn't
really doing anything.
So he wrote Disney.
Disney does a whole thing
on space [INAUDIBLE]..
But I think it's
an important aspect
in terms of really, who are you
stakeholders as a scientist.
You don't have-- unless
you're like a billionaire,
and even if you
are a billionaire,
you don't have the
power to manipulate--
you're not like the president.
So you have to be
able to figure out
how you're going
to persuade people
and how you're going to use
those different stakeholders
in a very interesting-- well,
in a very sort of pseudo
Machiavellian but
smart way, right?
And how do you play
the politics well?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So maybe there's
an amendment to the
legacy sector book
that we've been using
as our textbook, which
is part of the role of change
agents is to use the media
and to do storytelling.
Because this was a great story.
This was an amazing story,
which people in the United
States and the world followed
for a significant period
of time, this great rivalry.
And you know, Venter is
almost made for media
as a wonderful maverick, you
know, fascinating character.
And Collins is as well.
So there was a powerful
story to be told here
and a great competition
and a great race that
made it a very powerful
kind of media story
for an extended period of time.
So Louis, I had not anticipated
this tangent of the course.
But thanks for
pulling us into it.
So let me go on to the
next couple of readings.
So our textbook, who's got that?
Chloe, all yours.
AUDIENCE: So to set the stage
for maybe the first question
here.
I went to a talk recently
by a robotics entrepreneur,
which seems unrelated.
But I think he gave
an interesting lesson
as it relates, could
relate to health care.
He was talking about the
problem he was dealing with,
which was using robotics
as an organizational tool
in warehouses.
And it wasn't interesting
to me at first.
But he made the problem pretty
interesting after a while.
But the way that he framed
dealing with his problems
was that he practice having
the mindset of evaluating
the problem at zero and
infinity, as he said.
Which basically translated to
removing all constraints that
were pre-existing on the
system and then seeing you
know if he had infinite space
or infinite money or infinite
labor, what he could accomplish
or what his engineering
solutions would be.
And it was a really good
way to sort of brainstorm
an optimal solution
to his problem.
So I think it would
be interesting to take
the same approach to the
inherent problems in health
care delivery as
a legacy sector.
If we could-- like,
you made the point
that when you are recapping
this chapter that our system is
currently designed
to suit medicine
as it existed I guess
30 or 40 years ago,
but not as it is moving into
this exciting brave new world
today.
So if we could wipe
the slate clean
and not have any of
the residual costs,
like everyone started
out healthily today.
No one had any illness and we
didn't have any residual costs
or anything, like
perfect ideal world,
and we had to redesign
our health care
system from the ground
up, and --I know
this is a massive question.
But I'm just interested
in what you guys think
that might look like.
Like what would our
innovation in that area
look like we had no constraints.
AUDIENCE: I mean
obviously, you'd
have a bunch of
pharmaceutical companies
would be producing
infinite drugs,
because they have tons of money.
But from there, I think you'd
have a significant bottleneck
in terms of the FDA.
So you'd have to expand
that significantly.
AUDIENCE: I don't
necessarily mean like they
have the infinite resources.
It's just like if we were
starting to [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Create a
completely perfect system
for this time and the next
50 years, how would we do it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean, you
want me to give you
an answer of how to structure
or how to figure out
what the process is?
AUDIENCE: Just I guess, elements
of what it might look like.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
think a lot of it
falls in what Chris
was talking about
and what Bill was talking
about, the personalized medicine
component.
That's kind of how
they're touting it.
It's the fundamental
reorganization
of health care delivery.
And one of the ways
in which they're--
I guess, my understanding
is that the sector
is purporting to
make that happen is
through additive manufacturing.
So the 3D printing [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I was just
going to say that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, 3D printing
is going to be useful in
a lot of health areas.
So there's a new
manufacturing institute
that's organized around
regenerative medicine
and tissue engineering,
for example,
using 3D printing as one of the
technologies they're looking at
and combining that
with synthetic biology.
That's a very interesting and
potentially very promising
territory.
As we'll get into in the next
reading, that's not biology,
right?
That's a whole series of new
engineering strands that are
starting to enter
, and IT strands,
that are starting to
enter this territory.
And how does a system that's
not organized around that,
change to accommodate
those strands?
AUDIENCE: Well I think
the container section
of sort of the
pharmaceutical industry
and engineering, one of the
most interesting articles
that I read recently, was
about the ways in which they're
printing the pills in
order to be better adapted
to the person's absorption
of the medicine.
So they sort of--
they're starting to
develop ways to gauge
what a pill needs to look like
for an individual to ingest it
and also for the medicine to
be delivered into their body.
And They can't do that
in mass manufacturing.
They can only do that
in personalized medicine
through additives.
So I thought that
was pretty cool.
So that would be an answer
to your question, right?
That exists and does not
require an idealized world.
It would just require the sort
of commercialization process
and then the scaling up of
what exists potentially,
if it's not to be thwarted
by the legacy sector.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So the
traditional production system
for you know medicines is
a batch processing system.
You build a huge batch
and you refine it
so it has the perfect
composition spread
evenly throughout.
And then you produce that.
But that's frankly, not a
modern manufacturing technology.
So a continuous
manufacturing process
is much more flexible,
potentially much more modular
and adaptive to different
components in that system, i.e.
Different elements and a
different molecular structures
and different components within
a particular drug or a pill.
And 3D printing is a very
interesting adaptive approach.
So DARPA has been funding
desktop pharmaceutical
manufacturing with
exactly that in mind.
That we're going to have to
move to personalized medicine.
The military is going to have to
have it for its own huge health
care system, which is funded to
the tune of about $50 billion
a year, a major medical system.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
That's 10 arc reactors.
I'll take it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well it's
a very large medical system.
And they're having to deal
with changes and reforms
in their own system,
so they're moving
on developing a whole new set
of production technologies.
And on that one,
they've been working
within an MIT team that's
really quite interesting.
But that again, NIH
doesn't do this.
That's not in NIH's territory.
It happened that the military
was interested in this.
This new DARPA biological
technologies office
happens to be intrigued with
those set of possibilities.
But that's kind of outside the
box of the existing system.
AUDIENCE: So, plug and
play manufacturing,
plug and play
personalized medicine?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Good phrasing, Chloe.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I think we're going
to have to focus
on the new sexy technologies,
focus more on the structure.
Because I think like, say I have
to use the technology that we
have now, I would
think about how I'd
restructure the organization.
What are the problems and are
they caused by incentives?
So I think this
health care crisis
isn't a problem of technology
or even people or even doctors.
I think it's an
issue of incentives.
So when I say I'm going
to pay whatever you do,
I'm like, oh well, let's stack
it on, add more toppings.
And like, I end up
having a huge bill.
And then also, as a
generation, where now we
have a huge kind of--
I don't-- we have a lot more
elders than young people.
And so we have to pay
for these baby boomers.
So it ignores that context.
So we also might want
to focus on probably
like most of our
costs are going to go
to elders, not young people,
because young people are fine.
We have a huge portion
of elders, so what
are their diseases?
How do they work?
What are the main causes
of those diseases?
And how do I create my
organization around that?
Or maybe I just want to create
a whole new medical system,
focus on this segment
because I know
that they're going to be
huge, you know, costs.
And I can get you
know, laws of economics
by having such a
large segment that's,
like that whole system
is personalized for them.
And they have different needs
than somebody who is young.
Who can just take an
Uber or something.
Yeah.
For them, you probably have
to have somebody go directly
to them, check how they're
doing, check constant levels.
So it's very different.
And I think that
could cut costs down.
Or you could send
somebody out to them.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Or use
an IT system or use robotics.
Those are all part of
the menu that we're
starting to think
about Chloe, a closing
thought about this
reading on legacy sectors?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think for me,
it was really eye
opening to see the
part of the reading
where you just listed
the five or six specific
characteristics of how health
care delivery draws parallels
to legacy sectors.
And I think those are
probably the areas where
any sort of reformers
or innovators
would really hone
in on and focus
on lifting those restrictions
to limber up the system a lot.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: OK.
Let's go to the PCAST report.
AUDIENCE: Regarding this
research, the drug development.
We were just
talking about how do
we incentivize firms
to take on more
responsibility in developing
some drugs that target minority
groups or that don't
have such a big market.
And I want to introduce this
model that Singapore has in
incentivizing their small and
medium sized firms to invest
in R&D and trainings.
What they do is, you
can get a tax return
or you can get a
set amount of funds
as long as you are
investing in your employees
or in any forms of training that
can improve your productivity
and improves your
research in any form.
And I think Singapore was
able to do that because they
are really small scale.
And they also count on
their small and medium sized
businesses to thrive
as the economy.
But I want to know
if this kind of model
can be a good reference
to develop the health care
research sector in the US.
If you have any--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So the
model Singapore is using then
is to give an
incentive to companies
that are making significant
investments in the training
of their employees and
their research teams
to kind of significantly
upgrade their skill sets.
AUDIENCE: And they have
give a lot of flexibility.
As long as you can justify
this amount of spending,
or able to improve
your productivity,
they get this funding.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: That's
what you have to show.
You have to show some kind of
increased performance coming
out of that.
AUDIENCE: So what
are your thoughts
about this kind of approach that
could kind of encourage a drug
developments?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So that's interesting.
So that's like a roamer
technology talent approach
into a discussion we've
been having on institutional
innovation organization.
So it's again, you bring
us an interesting piece
of the puzzle.
I like it.
So let's go back to basics.
Is there a talent
need in this sector?
Is there a talent shortage?
Is there a talent
enthusiasm issue
here that we ought to
be addressing as well?
AUDIENCE: From what I've
seen in my very limited
biotech experience, it
seems like there isn't
really much of a shortage.
It seems like there's a lot of
enthusiasm around the field.
And like, as has
been a continuing
theme this class, our
good old American spirit
and our entrepreneurial drive
toward packing up and moving
out West or in this case west
is genetic engineering and all
that good stuff.
So I don't know if the
drive is really the problem.
AUDIENCE: I just think about--
I like to think about analogies.
And often in urban
planning, you know,
people compare
Scandinavian countries
to the rest of the world.
And say, well, why
can't we be like them?
And there's various
factors that we
don't take into
consideration, the homogeneity
of the population, their
productive capacity,
the resources they have
accessible to them,
the scale at which
they're operating,
maybe their colonial history
and the ways in which they
were able to sort of take
advantage of some opportunities
that we might not be able
to as a country, et cetera.
And so in this
instance, I'd like
to sort of invoke that and cross
apply that argument to sort
of Luyao's point
about Singapore,
and then to really utilize
that to challenge what Max just
said.
Because I feel like
we are situated
in a very unique and
incredible location
for this kind of conversation.
But where I'm from in Texas,
the kinds of university systems
and research system
that exist there,
these kinds of
conversations probably
don't happen to that extent.
And the enthusiasm
for commercialization
is probably not
to the same level.
And so I think I would
come back to what
Max is saying specifically,
by saying that perhaps we
need to then bring something,
in a way, usual socialist ways,
to say that perhaps it is the
kinds of talent that is missing
or rather, people from
marginalized groups
may have a decidedly public
good approach to research.
And so they might not want to
commercialize in the same ways
that people who are being
trained in institutions
like MIT and Stanford are.
And it is perhaps
that it is precisely
those people who the
government should be funding,
not major research
universities that
exist within a
commercialization framework.
Because those
individuals are less
likely to want to take the
bigger piece of the pie
and may potentially want
to benefit and serve
their communities
much more, which
could prove to be much
more disruptive ultimately.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Who wants to
take on Steph's economic model?
[LAUGHING]
Plenty of volunteers.
AUDIENCE: One, you directly
challenged me and you--
AUDIENCE: Please,
please, please, please.
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean,
it's nice and idealistic.
I love thinking that,
OK, everyone is just
going to work for free.
AUDIENCE: Oh I
don't think they're
going to work for free, Max.
That's not the insinuation.
The insinuation is that the
profit sharing is going to--
the.
Profit sharing model is going
to be much different I mean,
I'm not going to [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK, so I
understood it as they
don't care about making
big fish blockbuster drugs
or we'll make like the drugs
that are like [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: They can make the
big fish blockbuster drugs.
They just don't want to profit
to that extent, which ends up
being good for everyone.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So them not profiting
[INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: But the thing is,
you could take the other side.
The company's
profiting means they
can put that research-- put
that money toward new drugs,
as opposed to just
develop one drug
and then you
basically break even.
Then you're just like,
what do I do now?
AUDIENCE: I think
the focus on drugs
maybe also kind of limited.
Like I guess we still want
more drugs, that's fine.
But I think they have
drugs that are targeted
towards like, maybe if--
I guess we talked about
like a disease portfolio
that they look at
and it's very narrow.
And so there's two things here.
So I wonder if such proposals
might help expand that disease
portfolio.
So you have people who
care about more diseases
and are able to do more research
in sort of different areas.
And then two, I wonder if
those who actually subscribe
to this sort of, let's say big
pharma look kind of like we're
in this age, FDA, drug an
incremental advance type
system, do they actually
care to the extent
that someone's trying to get at.
Like are they
actually interested
in kind of solving this
incremental advance problem
or do they have a vested
interest in what they're
doing because they care about
these sort of bigger fish,
like kind of cure all drugs?
But they don't have the
funding opportunities and kind
of the means to kind
of get [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: The way
institutions are specifically
cited by the
conversions reading,
I think kind of really proved
sort of where I'm coming from.
They cited a Harvard,
University of Texas
at Austin, Carnegie Mellon,
George Tech, U Chicago,
and Tufts, obviously
you know without saying,
MIT, because most of the
people on that commission
had some relationship time or
were researchers that graduated
from MIT, were
professors that MIT,
were prominent political
stakeholders at MIT.
So you know it occurs
to me that there if, it
is that we you know really
revere people like Craig
Venter, and, if it is that
the convergence reading, which
we will be talking
about soon enough,
is putting a lot of weight
on the potential of community
colleges and of
local institutions
to train the workforce
in the life sciences,
why is it that we don't give
them the same access to funding
opportunities that
we're giving you know,
the sort of blockbuster
research universities?
AUDIENCE: I think the
big thing is like,
so it seems like a lot-- this
is like a easy mental model
for most people.
What they do is they think
about everything linearly.
So the thing is
like MIT, Harvard,
and luxury institutions just
have a huge conglomeration
of people.
So they're exponentially
much better
at solving certain problems.
And they have the credibility
to go and get funding
from outside sources,
whether it be government,
whether it be VC, so it
is this huge you know,
very unproportional
nature of the institutes
and the way the system works.
But there are some
good things to that.
What I worry more is like how
do you create a new system
to make all these smaller
drugs and working on them
more viable.
So I think that's an
interesting place for a startup,
if you can figure out
3D printing of drugs
or if you can figure
out what is your kind
of your competitive
advantage in this problem.
And what is the
current structure
for the company that
focus on the big pharma.
And how do you
optimize for that.
So what are so it's pretty
much like Art of War.
It's like, OK, they already
have their strategy.
They have to focus on
doing business with us.
And there's also called
the intervention dilemma,
which is like they
have to make $5 billion
in revenue off of this drug.
I don't need to make
$5 million in revenue.
I'm a smaller fish.
I could, with like
$5 million, right?
So like how do I create my
systems so that I can make
these kind of drugs and
make a big company based
on focusing on
those smaller drugs
that are important to society.
That would be like the
enterprise version.
You can probably come up with
some parallel using government
funding and government support.
And maybe it might be that
FDA approval, being more lax,
or depending on
the drug, I would
have to figure out which
ones are the best ones
to go after in the beginning.
But I don't think, except
making the argument
that, oh how do we, you know, I
don't want to say democratize,
but why can't everybody
like be in the pool?
Especially when it's
like those there
are people that are
Olympic swimmers
and like institutes that--
I mean there are probably
good high school swimmers,
but like it just won't you
won't get as much a run through
of the same--
AUDIENCE: I guess
it just concerns me
that we pay so much lip service
to the great groups model.
And the great group model itself
says that the drive for profit
is not the greatest
motivator to innovation.
And if we are to
consider that as true
or to take that at face value
in the ways in which the authors
have presented their argument
in the previous weeks,
I don't know that
the commercialization
model for the life
sciences is necessarily
conducive to innovations in
the ways in which we would
hope that they would exist.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So, Steph, you're
driving us towards obviously
some truly big picture issues.
Look, we have taken a pretty
radical capitalist model
to solving this problem of
innovation in life science,
right?
It's pretty amazing
that we have focused
on a high risk, high
reward system that's
completely dependent
upon you know,
monopoly rents and major returns
as the way in which we're
going to do innovation in
the life science territory.
It's absolutely fascinating.
How did we stumble into this?
That wasn't what-- remember
when we talked about Boyer
and the conflicts he had
with other UCSF faculty?
When he went off to invent the
biotech model with Swanson,
he got a lot of flack for this.
That was a radical departure.
He was leaving a university
based research system.
But let's think back to the
reasons why he was doing that.
Because he wanted
his technologies
to scale up and be available
and that was the option
that he saw for being
able to do that,
so he teams up with Swanson.
I don't think we're going to
resolve these questions today.
But it is a radical
capitalist model.
And as we've discussed
at length today,
there are gaps in
that model, right?
There's only some
things that that model
is going to be able
to address given
the structural limits
that are coming into it,
particularly the long
term approval process
that the FDA has to provide.
So you know, drug
companies hate the FDA
because they have to spend
seven years and $1.8 billion
getting through their hurdles.
But they also love FDA because
it certifies their products
and guarantees a
market for them.
So it's this odd love
hate relationship.
In some ways that's
symptomatic of what we've
got over this whole system.
And it is a system under
stress at this point.
Luyao why don't you give us a
closing point on this and then
we'll go right into what I
think the next part of the story
is on convergence.
Because I think it
fits nicely with this.
AUDIENCE: I realize we do focus
on a lot of how to incentivize
innovation in drug development.
But I do think that
you know we still
have this scarcity problem
with rising demand and limited
supply.
Why don't we also divert
a little bit of focus
on developing a
healthy population.
Can any form of drug
development and kind of research
that advance this
process, so that we
can reduce the unnecessary
demand for certain type
of health care.
So that we can free up a bit
of our funding and resources
so that we can focus on the
rest of the research programs.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
look, your point earlier,
which we debated about, is
there a talent problem here?
Romer's prospector
theory would tell us,
you're going to get
a lot more innovation
if you put more well-trained
prospectors on the problem,
right?
So I don't want us to
kind of leave that point.
I think there's an
interesting underlying point
you made in that area as well.
All right, let's go on
to the convergence study.
The report is called
"The Third Revolution
- The Convergence Of Life,
Physical and Engineering
Sciences."
And it came out of MIT in 2011.
You know my office, the
MIT Washington office,
helped work on this.
The project was led by
Phil Sharpe and Bob Langer,
somebody from engineering,
somebody from biology,
obviously two of
MIT's all time greats.
And the report tries
to tell a story
that the picture in the
next advance wave, we're
lacking a picture of the
next wave of advance.
The great thing the
genomes piece gave
us and we talked about
Venter and the competition
with Collins and the
NIH, it gave us a story,
it gave us a picture
of what we're
going to get for this
massive investment in NIH.
It enabled the public to see
a story and be told a story
and understand what the results
were going to yield, right?
We don't have a story
for the life sciences
that's out there now that
has nearly the kind of power
as that genomic story.
We haven't figured out how
to tell the next story.
And that's part
of the reason why
we've got funding
stagnation for NIH
and the life
sciences in general.
So the doubling was led by
the genomics revolution.
NIH needs a new picture.
So what are these
different revolutions?
So what this report
argued was that really
the kind of first
revolution in recent time
was the molecular
biology revolution.
And that was really the
merger of physics and biology.
So Max Delbruck comes out of the
amazing pre-war German physics
community.
He works with Niels
Bohr in Copenhagen
as part of that
amazing community that
were living in Bohr's
house, being trained by him.
Bohr produces this
amazing talent team
and this is the
second generation.
This is you know
Bohr and Einstein are
an earlier generation and
Marie Curie and so forth.
This is the next generation out.
How are they going to
find their project?
What's their
project going to be?
And Bohr kind of urges Delbruck,
why don't you look at biology.
We're coming along up with
a lot of physics here.
Is there a way of
applying that to biology?
And Delbruck does this and has
to come to the United States.
He has to flee Germany
on the eve of the war.
And in turn,
Salvadore Luria, he is
working with Enrico Fermi
at the University of Rome.
He's a medical doctor.
He's trained in medicine.
And he is fascinated
with physics.
So he goes to work for Fermi,
working on particle physics
issues.
So these are two
people that actually
lead this whole molecular
biology revolution, in part
because they're doing this
crossover thing that we've
talked about before.
They're taking physics and
moving it into this new biology
territory with a whole
new raft of ideas
that help mature and create
all kinds of new thinking
in biology.
And it really leads to
molecular biology, right?
You know, the second revolution
is really genome sequencing.
We've talked a lot
about that already.
But essentially, that's another
one of these crossovers, right?
That's taking
advances in computing
and certain other kind
of physical science areas
and then bringing
them into biology
and creating a whole new set
of applications in the biology
field that are in
turn transformative.
So that's a second crossover.
The third revolution--
here, by the way,
are some of the earlier
revolution leaders.
So that's Salvadore Luria,
one of MIT'S greats,
Nobel Prize winner.
That's Luria and Delbruck
teamed up together
on the back porch of I think
some Long Island beach resort.
Luria works in
Cold Spring Harbor.
But that's you know, that's
an amazing talent team.
And they really do create the
intellectual underpinnings
for molecular biology.
That's Leroy Hood, inventor
who you're familiar with.
That's Eric Lander.
They're leaders in
the second revolution,
the great genomic revolution,
another crossover approach.
And then we've got this
whole new community.
I've featured the
MIT parts of it.
But this revolution is
happening at many other schools.
But this is just the
community that we're used to.
So Phil Sharp on the
left and Bob Langer,
who are the leaders on
this particular report.
Tyler Jacks who leads
the Koch Institute here.
Paul Hammond, who is chairman
of the biochemistry department,
no.
AUDIENCE: Chem E.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Chemical
engineering department.
But is doing an enormous amount
of research in the life science
side.
Susan Hockfield is president
at Sangeeta Bhatia, who's
doing amazing work on cancer.
You know, it's an incredible
community of talent,
again from a whole series
of different kind of fields.
It's another crossover.
It's engineering and
physical sciences
and computational sciences
entering into the life science
space with a whole new set
of disciplinary perspectives,
a whole new set of systems
perspectives, a whole new way
of thinking about how
to organize research.
And so this is
the MIT community.
You could duplicate this
at other schools as well.
But it's a set of engineering
tools are going to come here,
but also a whole concept of
engineering design comes here.
So, life science systems tends
to look at that complexity.
They tend to look
at complex systems
and attempt to understand the
elements in complex systems.
That's the kind of way,
the frame that biologists
work from.
Engineering works in a
very different kind of way.
It attempts to organize in
a very hierarchical fashion
and set priorities.
Engineering design is
a very different way
of looking at the world.
So these two fundamental
different perspectives
now have the opportunity
of coming together here,
for what becomes actually a
very different kind of research
model.
So there will be new
knowledge bases here that
come about as a result of this.
Just as genomics gave us a
whole new knowledge base,
just as molecular biology gave
us a whole new knowledge base,
the convergence of
these different fields
is going to create a
new knowledge base.
But convergence is
somewhat different.
Because it's also, particularly
through the engineering side,
it could lead us to a whole new
set of therapeutic advances.
So new technologies shift
over from engineering
in areas like imaging sensors,
nanotechnology, simulation
modeling, probability,
these are all kind
of engineering led sides
of things that can now
walk into the biology space.
So this report at MIT kind of
laid a lot of the groundwork.
And frankly Susan
Hockfield saw the promise
of what these folks
were writing about
and created you know
just, up the road from us
created the Koch
Institute, so that we
were walking the walk
at the same time we
were talking the talk here.
So that Koch Institute
was under way
before this report
was even finished,
because it was just so clear
that this was an incredibly
promising set of new research
opportunities that were going
to create a lot of real
breakthrough spaces
in the life sciences.
So there's a whole
series of strands
that we had already
seen, that you could
call convergence-like
strands, so synthetic biology
and nano biology and systems
biology, bioinformatics,
computational biology,
tissue engineering, these
were all kind of strands at MIT
and in life sciences generally.
And the idea of convergence
was, ah, these things
are doing similar things.
We can understand this
in a larger kind of way
and take more creative
advantage of it.
So will convergence play a
role in the medical costs
problems that we've
been talking about?
We talked about the lack of
incentives for cost controls
in the system.
So far, we've been thinking
about health care as a,
like rearranging the kind of
financial plumbing, right?
Could we create different kinds
of cost structures and cost
incentives and so forth.
There is another
potential answer here,
and it's back to the
prospector theory in a way
that you were suggesting.
Maybe there are innovation
answers here too, right?
In other words, if
you get a whole series
of innovation based
advances, that
can tackle a lot
of these problems.
So for example, you
know, NIH working away
in supporting life
science research
really enabled huge progress
against heart disease, which
you know, is breathtaking
and really moved
heart disease down a notch
from a nightmare killer
to much more manageable
health problem.
And that's occurred
in the last 25 years.
If you do that in
a number of areas,
you can really start to
affect the whole kind of cost
structure.
And particularly, could
you have healthier aging?
So one part of the dilemma
for the current demographics
challenge that's
going to be upon you,
is keeping my generation
in the workforce
longer with returns that
are going into society.
Can you make me
and my generation
work longer, generating returns
that get distributed to all?
That would solve
a lot of problems.
That helps us, rather
than walking off a cliff,
it helps it manage
much more of a curve.
So if we could do that,
that would be powerful.
And may be that some of these
convergence space technologies
can really be significant
enablers in ways
that we kind of
never saw before.
So that's an innovation-based
policy approach
to a profound kind of
societal challenge.
So there's a whole
series of policy steps
that the report argues
need to be taken.
We need to get across
NIH stovepipes.
NIH, which is all biology
all the time on most days,
needs to be encouraged to
be able to look at and fund
other fields.
It's hard for NIH to
do it because it's
composed of biologists.
If it analyzes proposals that
involve complex engineering,
how does it do the analysis?
How does it have
multidisciplinary peer review
systems?
Is it able to
encourage RO1s that
have multiple PIs, not
sole single PIs, that
represent a series of different
fields and disciplines.
It's how do we do
education and convergence?
So we still have stove
piped disciplinary fields,
and they're producing
a lot of talent.
But how do they get educated
in these other fields
so they can take
advantage of it?
Do we need a new
kind of approach
in life science education?
And what are the of common
language features going to be?
Steph.
AUDIENCE: I feel like
the report was really
missing an element about the
jobs in the convergence field,
because there's not really many
job opportunities for people
who are trained in
multidisciplinary
understandings.
And I feel like there would
be an enormous insecurity
or uncertainty for those people
who are interested in pursuing
the really innovative fields
if they don't understand
what the actual next step is
after a university education.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
There's no question about it.
This is a dilemma.
And look, this has been
a dilemma for a while
for bioengineering departments.
I think we're getting
out of that phase.
I think those are starting
to really kind of take off,
in part because this
model is taking off.
But we don't have
clear pathways.
So I mean the model is going
to continue to be that you're
going to be a biologist.
But can you get access to
a series of other fields?
Maybe you're an engineer but
you get significant access
to a series of medical
related fields as well.
Can we adjust our training
system and modify it so that--
there was a talented staffer
in my office who said look,
we we're going to need
a new language here
in life science innovation.
We're going to need kind
of our convergence Creole,
a mix of different languages
from different fields
so that people are going
to be able to speak
across these disciplinary
lines and understand things
across these disciplinary lines.
That could be that could
be pretty important.
You know that's the
heart of this report.
MIT team subsequently went
on in a much broader based
report that went across
many institutions.
And this past year, did a
report looking at what could we
get from convergence?
In other words, what other
promising convergence areas
and what might be obtained
from them in an attempt
to get a much more strategic
approach to convergence?
Not just say
convergence is neat,
which is kind of
what this report did.
But really get a
strategy together.
I'm partly guilty.
But actually get a
strategy together
around what territories
in convergence
might be particularly promising.
So I urge you to take a look
at that more recent report.
That was much more widely
shared across institutions.
Luyao, some questions for us.
AUDIENCE: I think one of the
most relevant discussions
of the [INAUDIBLE] would be
what are the possible features
that we could expect in
university level that
will be probably encouraging
this kind of confidence
to take place?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean, we have the
whole liberal arts college.
It's essentially
the liberal arts
for science and
engineering model.
AUDIENCE: But why is
it currently not--
like since they're
proposing this convergence
of researchers, so why
is it not happening
with all this students with
multidisciplinary backgrounds,
why are they not
currently working together
across disciplines?
AUDIENCE: I would say, in
no particular reference
to our institution at Wellesley.
I work a lot with
multidisciplinary stakeholders
for the incubator program that
I am facilitating currently.
And a big concern that
faculty members have
is that they, one,
by the administration
are not facilitated
to do collaborations.
And two, that a
lot of people feel
like having an entrepreneurship
or a sort of innovation
for the purpose of
commercialization model
goes against the spirit of
a liberal arts education.
So I feel like in
that sense, you know,
research universities are
very much well-designed
to sort of adopt more
of a liberal arts model
than I think liberal arts
colleges are designed
to adopt more of a stem model.
But you know, perhaps
somewhere in there
is a model that can arise about
multidisciplinary coordination.
But it would
require facilitation
by the administration
to the extent
to which I think
MIT does a really
great job of facilitating that
at the institutional level.
AUDIENCE: The rise of kind
of these collaborative
projects, particularly
culminating
in your senior year, I
think capstone projects
are a great opportunity
to start encouraging
these collaborative efforts.
I think Course Two
does this pretty well
with their 2.009
Mechancial Engineering
kind of product design course.
But the piece that I
would take from that
is at the beginning
of the semester,
they have you list
all of your skills.
And they separate you out
based on kind of backgrounds
and then form teams that are
like inherently collaborative,
so you don't have sort of
lumpiness and all the students
that are interested, or
have particular backgrounds
in product design, they're
not all on the same team.
They kind of spread it out.
And then I think if it be
an interesting exercise
to have MIT do sort of a school
engineering capstone project.
And sort of elect
into a course where
you have people that
are interested in tissue
engineering, but they come
from the biology department,
the chemical
engineering department,
and bioengineering department,
and they work together
to kind of formalize this.
AUDIENCE: In my impression,
there's kind of two models.
Either we train more
multidisciplinary students
like, for me, like my major
is philosophy, politics,
and economics.
But I'm not actually
in [INAUDIBLE]..
So then the other
option is to have
like a lot of very
focused students
and bring them together
to work as a team.
Which model do you think will
be more effective in addressing
health care change?
AUDIENCE: I think
great groups model.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: You
definitely like want
people that like, what's
the difference between--
AUDIENCE: It's the
deep generalist.
That's what they
were calling them.
AUDIENCE: No.
Well, you need one
person who can gets it
for every single
one of the issues.
But then you need somebody
who-- you need somebody who is
obsessed--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Yo, I read
every single book.
I read two, three books
outside this course.
You know, I know this
and this and this.
And the person is
just like, like,
knows so much that like,
it's just like you hit them
with like, any word
and they're inspired.
So like, you want--
but you definitely need somebody
who knows it and understands
how to lead really.
Well.
Because really great
engineers tend to not
be able to communicate greatly.
So you have to be able
to figure out and ask
what questions to ask that they
won't tell you or figure out
what they're not
telling you, especially
when hitting deadlines.
And then another big
part with groups,
with these kind of
groups, is to figure out
where each person stands.
So it's like, oh, I don't
think you're doing a great job.
Or I know you have
this deadline.
You might may not make it.
I know you're stressed.
Don't be stressed.
I'll check in at the 70% mark.
How are you doing and then
we'll figure it out from there.
But I don't know,
I think is more
interesting to the
research and the media lab
kind of does that.
But I don't know
if it's been done
for very, very hard research.
What I would consider
super, like solving
like a very hard problem.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
It's all these problems
are now at hand, as we
start to seriously pursue
this convergence model,
exactly how we're
going to cope with this.
Susan Hockfield used
to talk about it.
And other people have talked
about it too, T-shaped people.
In other words, people
with a deep disciplinary
die, but capable of operating
across fields as well.
And that may well be a
pretty key feature here.
And then combining
that community so
it's able to communicate
with each other.
But you draw on a series
of different fields.
So what the organizational
model is going to be
is really critical here.
Because again as we've
talked about two classes ago,
innovation, you know,
happens with people.
It's not these institutional
organizational models.
And how do you optimize the
opportunities for people
to be creative?
So that's upon
this model, right?
Koch Institute is spending a
lot of time thinking about this.
But actually Koch
Institute is only one part
of the convergence
going on at MIT.
Something like 130
engineers are now
working a significant
amount of their time
at I'm MIT on the
life science side.
And that's not unique.
That's going on at a
lot of institutions now.
And NIH is a problem here.
Because it hasn't
caught up to be
able to manage that
kind of transition
and embrace these
different fields.
So that's the big funder.
And how do we bring
that institution along?
AUDIENCE: I think my
big concern though,
is like having all
academics, like, yeah, we're
getting T people
but, let's define
T like somebody who
is like a grad student
or undergrad at MIT.
Like I don't know
if the best answer
is to have a great group of Ts.
You know, I want some As.
I want some Bs.
I want some accents.
I want some question marks.
Because like, I would use all
sorts, like the background,
right?
Because it is the
difference between,
oh, I can make a really good
like bistro sandwich versus I
need to make 100,
1,000, 100,000.
And I need to have
the financials
for all of the stuff, which
is like McDonald's, right?
So ideally, I
would want somebody
who's already been in
the field, like somebody
who has faculty experience.
Because I might start to
build out a certain way.
But they have just a big
scene phenomena, right?
Like a great example
is, originally
GE, when they were putting
out the electrical lens,
there was this guy
named Steinmetz.
He was this hunchback
immigrant that couldn't even
speak English when he
got to the country,
and didn't really have a great--
do you have Steinmetz on there?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I don't.
AUDIENCE: It would
be cool if you did.
But, yeah, but he was just
like this very, very kind
of somebody who would
never even be at MIT.
Or like the Wright
brothers, right?
That it was just they had
the practice experience
that, oh, I think I can
do this and trying it out.
Also like just because
of, as in academics,
there's always a flaw
in any organization.
And you have to figure out,
especially in business,
you look at, oh, how
can I expose their flaw
and they're never going
to be able to go here
because of the way.
This is their blind spot.
And so like, you can
definitely, like what
happened at the Wright
brothers, where it's like,
I can't work on this
problem because there's
no perfect theory and
it's too much of a risk.
And I'm already 50 years old.
And I'm not trying
to risk my reputation
and make my friends
make fun of me
because that's
too uncomfortable.
And I've already kind
of like gone my way.
And there might be somebody
that's like, you know,
it's pretty crazy
but I'm just going
to try it and see what happens.
And I think in that paper, there
is a quote, where it's like,
what's the point of
research if you already
know what's going to happen?
But the way the
system is, sometimes
it incentivizes you
to just do like,
oh, I know this is
never going to--
I don't know if it's
going to be perfect.
But I know it's pretty
much going to work out.
And I think that's a very--
OK, as like somebody
who likes capitalism,
I think that's a
huge opportunity.
Because like, you don't
just make your company look
at all the blind spots.
But I think that's going
to be one of the reasons
why these models don't succeed.
And it will be big failure too.
If they fail, right?
Because of you like you said.
You spent all this money.
You got all these smart people.
And there can be a
huge failure there.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So let's close.
I attempted to put the
convergence reading last
because it's
basically a positive.
In other words, there are
huge innovation opportunities
that are at hand that
we're starting to move on.
So despite all the problems
in the innovation system
in this sector and all of
its organizational gaps,
something really interesting
is starting to happen.
So let me close with a comment
from Elias Zerhouni, who
is the Director of NIH
before Francis Collins.
He writes, "As science
grows more complex,
it is also converging on a
set of unifying principles
that link apparently
disparate diseases
through common
biological pathways
and therapeutic approaches.
Today NIH research needs to
reflect this new reality."
So I think that's our innovation
organization task here,
I think summarized nicely
in a couple of sentences
from Zerhouni.
A closing thought, Luyao?
AUDIENCE: Well, I do think this
reading sends a very positive
message that we
will need to search
for a holistic organization
that kind of get our resources
and tackle these problems.
Still, I also feel
like we are not
addressing the
problem of kind of,
instead of tackling all these
diseases, why don't we prepare,
like kind of advocate
this population to be
more healthy, to encourage them
to have a healthier lifestyle.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Preventative
medicine rather than
just repair jobs.
Right, right.
An important thought.
AUDIENCE: And I do think--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
there aren't incentives
in this system particularly
to do that either,
which is problematic.